bonjour à tous votre journal de la
mi-journée le crash de l'a320 le temps
des interrogations comment une merveille
de technologie at elle pu faire défaut
le pilote chevronné qu'il était trop sûr
de lui le pilotage à 2 est il remis en
question l'avenir commercial de
l'appareil est il compromis
la méthode rocard radioscopie d'un
accord menée avec efficacité et sobriété
de long hospitalisé pour une rupture de
ligament après une semaine mouvementée
nous étions hier à sa sortie de clinique
il raconte c'est une exclusivité antenne
2 météo la tendance tout de suite avec
sophie davant et une couverture nuageuse
importante aujourd'hui sur l'ensemble du
pays il y aura des orages dans le sud
est
tant localement plus vieux dans le
nord-ouest et entre les deux teams
d'éclaircies se développeront le dernier
bilan de la catastrophe dachan fait état
de trois morts sans 33 rescapés dans une
cinquantaine de blessés hospitalisés
l'airbus a320 vous allez le voir était
en vol de démonstration vitesse 300 km
heure c'est à dire faible vitesse basse
altitude 30 pieds c'est à dire entre 10
et 15 mai effectué deux passages dessus
de l'aérodrome et c'est au cours du
premier passage qu'il s'est écrasé
n'arrivant pas à reprendre de l'altitude
regardez
m
oulala aux yeux
oh non non non non non
[ __ ] alors aussi maintenant les
premiers témoignages ont été recueillis
sur place hier parmi les passagers qui
ont pu quitter l'appareil par l'arrière
ce sont eux qui sont indemnes
témoignages recueillis également auprès
des spectateurs de ce meeting aérien
tout s'est passé très vite selon
plusieurs témoins un choc a été
ressentie juste avant la lisière des
arbres heureusement les portes de
l'appareil se sont alors ouvertes alors
que l'avion commençait à brûler et la
louve et comme tu en étais j'ai fait
assez bas est allé rouler remonté il a
touché la cime des arbres là bas
derrière et l'avion a pris feu tout ça
fait tout de suite via l'intérieur ce
qu'il ya eu des cris comment ça moi
j'étais juste à côté de la frontière dès
ce soir du 1er mai le topo vent était
déjà un peu le travail n'était pas dire
que des arbres j'ai sauté les dirigeants
il y avait beaucoup de blessés vous
savez là je ne sais pas qu'est dior
quand je suis arrivé dans la dans la
forêt y avait les gens qui couraient
dans tous les sens ça criait je
demandais aux gens ce qu'il suffisait ci
se promener ou quoi nous on était dans
l'avion des parts et ça va ça va
exploser bon là sur place il ya une
hôtesse on a demandé une hôtesse
l'hôtesse a dit il ya plus personne ne
lancer c'est pas la peine je pense que
c'était plutôt pour nous qu on ne
s'approche pas trop près de l'appareil
et puis après bombe en essayer de
regarder s'il y avait d'autres personnes
on a dégagé des personnes qui se
trouvait accroché un peu dans les
branches dans les dents les aidants et
autour de l'avion quoi et on les a
dégagées de plus pour les éloigner de
l'appareil les tisons qu' il était ont
de fait il s'est écrasé et les gens
crier tu as eu peur qu est ce que tu as
fait et avec ton père est ce que tu as
fait sauter de l'avion peu après les
pompiers qui sont venus ils montent à 6
la première image du commandant de bord
vous allez le voir
le commandant est encore très
commotionné quant aux sons nous devons
de le recevoir là aussi ce n'est pas
très haut dit vous le voyez là sur son
lit
sortie l'occident et j'ai empêché la
presse de couteau mais sinon l ac river
pour mon vers la sortie
le commandant en parler de ses camarades
dans l'avion un moment donné dit elle a
crié il faisait allusion ray
semblablement a eu nos tests avant de
s'interroger sur les responsabilités à
savoir défaillance technique défaillance
humaine
arrêtons-nous sur l'opportunité de la
présence d'un tel appareil au cours d'un
meeting aérien il faut savoir que cet
a320 était flambant neuf
il devait d'être baptisé prochainement
ville d'amsterdam et en était à son
septième vol commercial il avait été
livré jeudi dernier à la compagnie air
france
mais curieusement sa présence au meeting
d'habsheim était plus ou moins annoncé
le préfet du haut rhin avait précisé
dans une conférence de presse que le vol
ne figurait pas dans les papiers
officiels de la manifestation aérienne
et de son côté le président d'air france
a déclaré qu'on l'avait assuré que
toutes les autorisations avaient bien
été donné alors au delà de cette
polémique administrative disons le il
faut attendre en tout cas un examen des
deux boîtes noires retrouvées à
proximité de l'appareil enquête françois
corner l'airbus a320 d'air france à
14h20 hier sur l'aéroport de
bâle-mulhouse dans le cockpit le
commandant de bord michal astin à gauche
chef de secteur de la division a320
d'air france chargé de la formation des
pilotes sur ce type d'appareil à ses
côtés pierre mazières directeur de
l'instruction du personnel navigant sur
airbus a320 deux pilotes aux commandes
pour un vol de 45 minutes au dessus du
mont blanc avec à bord 138 passagers
danser pour la plupart le baptême de
l'air à dix kilomètres d'ici sur le
petit aérodrome de habsheim un meeting
aérien qui réunit chaque année quinze à
vingt mille personnes
un meeting qui va démarrer l'airbus lui
qui va décoller à 14h45 de mulhouse doit
ouvrir ce meeting par une présentation à
basse altitude au-dessus de l'aérodrome
d'habsheim question que vient faire
l'airbus a320 nouvel appareil dans un
meeting aérien réponse
l'avion a été louée par plusieurs aéro
clubs de la région pour deux vols de
démonstration dans le courant de l'après
midi
la plupart des 138 passagers qui avaient
embarqué pour le premier vol avaient
payé leur place 600 francs chacun
d'autres les avait gagnés dans une
tombola
curieux tout de même que le préfet du
haut-rhin monsieur d'izard n'ait pas été
mise au courant de ce vol on ne lui
avait pas semble-t-il demandé son
autorisation dans l'arrêté qu'il avait
signé les avions effectuant des
démonstrations de vol acrobatique
devront être pourvus d'un certificat de
navigabilité portant la mention
acrobaties autrement dit mon arrêté bien
sûr qui est soumis à tous les avis des
techniciens moi en tant qu'ami trésor
général j'ai simplement donné une
autorisation sous réserve effectivement
que des autorisations spéciales soit
donnée par ailleurs et c'est tout ce que
je peux dire je veux pas dire si en
amont ou en aval
l'airbus était mentionné il n'était pas
dans mon arrêté ou dans le dossier de
mon arrêté
c'est tout ce que je peux dire furieux
encore que daniel brennan baume
directeur général de l'aviation civile
ne sache pas non plus que l'airbus
devaient effectuer cette démonstration
est ce que les autorisations avaient été
demandées avoir connaissance de tous
question pourquoi l'airbus se présente
il aussi bas en approche de habsheim
il n'est pas là pour éblouir d'éventuels
acheteurs et surtout pourquoi des
centaines à 30 pieds 10 m au dessus du
sol avec 137 passagers à bord
les deux pilotes sont de grands
professionnels il n'y a aucune raison
qu'il prenne le moindre risque et ce
bruit caractéristique de la remise des
gaz que l'on devrait entendre ici pour
qu'après avant les arbres et que l'on
entend pas pourquoi beaucoup de
questions pour l'instant sans réponse
mais manifestement un miracle dans ce
crash celui de 133 personnes qui vont
réussir à s'extraire de l'appareil alors
que les ailes en fermant le kérosène
désarticulé déchiquetés par les arbres
sont déjà en flammes et que la cabine va
s'embraser
alors que des familles sur l'aéroport de
mulhouse attendent
tél le retour d'un enfant ou d'un parent
qui se trouvaient à bord
problème technique dans la remise des
gaz erreur humaine
toute la nuit les secouristes ont
fouillé les débris dans lesquelles ils
ont retrouvé la boîte noire
l'enregistreur de vol dans les
informations permettront peut-être d'en
savoir plus en attendant des témoins
dans le barman de l'aéro club de
habsheim intervenus dans les premiers
sur les lieux affirme lui que l'airbus
n'a pas remis les gaz moi je suis arrivé
j'ai aidé plusieurs personnes à sortir
ne veulent pas de l'appareil les gens
glisser sur les toboggans
je suis discuter j'ai demandé au
commandant de bord qui étaient là mais
enfin qui était quand même assez secoué
je lui ai
je vais enlever la cravate dégrafer la
chemise est ouvert la chine assure du
pantalon et j alors qu'est ce qui s'est
passé il m'a dit j'ai mis la pêche et ça
n'a pas subi ce matin la commission d'
enquête a commencé ses investigations et
interrogez elles aussi les témoins de ce
crash que personne encore ne s'explique
alors venant en précisément explication
plus exactement
vous l'avez compris en attendant
l'examen des boîtes noires dont on nous
dit qu'il sera rapide
retenons quelques hypothèses qui
répondent aux questions simples que je
vous répète telles que comment ce
biréacteur qui est le fin du fin de la
technologie aéronautique européenne at
il pu être pris en défaut oui ou non
et puis comment deux pilotes chevronnés
instructeur de surcroît ont-ils pu
commettre une erreur s'ils tentaient
qu'ils ont commis une erreur et je vous
rappelle ce témoignage très important
donc de l'un des membres de l'équipe de
secours que nous venons d'entendre le
pilote de l'avion aurait bien dit j'ai
voulu remettre les gaz et ça n'a pas
suivi
patrick esther
regardez bien l'intégralité de cet
enregistrement vidéo et surtout écoutez
bien le son des réacteurs
ce document est une pièce à verser au
dossier de l'enquêté technique
maintenant reprenons à l'instant où le
pilote présente l'airbus a320 face à la
piste pour s'aligner il va basculer
l'avion sur la droite mais la piste est
courte
c'est un aérodrome c'est donc à cet
instant que le pilote doit apprécier son
altitude ainsi que la hauteur des arbres
en bout de piste mais il est manifeste
que l'appareil est trop bas peut-être
une erreur d'appréciation
sachant que le diamètre de la cabine est
de 4 m on peut constater que les roues
du train d'atterrissage est là que sont
à dix mètres du sol
mais plus grave compte tenu de
l'inclinaison de l'appareil le pilote ne
peut plus voir les premiers rangs
d'arbres c'est l'instant où il devrait
pousser la puissance des moteurs pour
remonter mais le son le prouve la remise
des gaz ne se fait que plus tard un
dixième de secondes seulement avant que
les roues touchent les arbres c'est fini
une panne
auraient-elles retarder la montée en
puissance des moteurs c'est possible
mais peu probable
il reste que les deux hommes aux
commandes étaient tous deux chefs pilote
aux manettes se trouvait michel asseline
un très bon pilote très sûr de lui
peut-être trop sûr de lui alors l'a320
nous vous en avons souvent parlé de cet
airbus la polémique était vive et ne
s'était pas éteint des navigants de la
compagnie air inter refusé le pilotage à
2 or comme l'avait souligné le ministre
des transports louis mermaz du même cet
avion a été conçu pour deux pilotes
étaient lequel il avait fait l'objet de
500 options et de 319 commandes fermes
deux interrogations maintenant le
pilotage de va-t-il être remis en
question et puis l'avenir commercial de
l'appareil est il compromis
voici les faits les premières décisions
en tout cas une compagnie japonaise qui
avait commandé vingt airbus a décidé de
maintenir sa confiance dans l'avion
européen réaction identique pour une
compagnie australienne de même pour les
allemands de lufthansa et pour les
espagnols d'iberia les anglais eux ont
décidé de suspendre les vols de leurs
deux airbus a320 en attendant de plus
amples informations quant aux réactions
syndicales et patronales
elle s'oppose maryse mano 34 mois trente
quatre mois de conflit où les pilotes
des rentes ai réclame grève à l'appui
une période d'essai de pilotage à 3 sur
l'airbus
a320 la disparition du mécanicien à bord
justifié par l'automatisation de
l'appareil se fait selon les syndicats
au détriment de la sécurité
le 18 avril air france met en service
son premier a320 piloter a2r inter
inaugure la semaine dernière le vol
paris re noble dans les mêmes conditions
les syndicats ont perdu mais l'accident
d'hier pourrait renforcer leurs
positions
un argument supplémentaire en leur
faveur vient d'être déposé dans la
corbeille de leurs revendications de
leurs arguments c'est eux qui vont gérer
cette affaire
je ne sais pas comment ils vont faire
monsieur certain que si le moindre doute
technique esi et existe sur le sujet ils
vont s'en emparer les compagnies elles
sont formels désir soir air france
prenait les devants pour que personne ne
peut vraiment dire personne ne peut
affirmer que le problème de pilotage à
deux buts à quatre heures soit un lien
quelconque avec l'accident que
malheureusement nous déplorons rouge ce
matin air inter a suspendu le vol paris
grenoble sur a320 comme toutes les
compagnies de lancement de l'appareil
jusqu'aux conclusions de l'enquêté reste
que l'accident en pleine période de
lancement de coûter cher à
l'aérospatiale qui a d'ailleurs vendu
plus de 500 avions a320 les japonais
confirme leur commande de vingt airbus
malgré l'accident tout comme les
australiens qui attendent leur premier
appareil en novembre mais les
mécaniciens de ce pays remettent en
cause le pilotage à 2 voilà pour ce
dossier concernant la catastrophe de
chime l'europe maintenant la monnaie
européenne ne verra probablement pas le
jour à l'issue du sommet de hanovre qui
s'ouvre aujourd'hui mais on ne va parler
que de ça les 12 chefs d'état et de
gouvernement de la communauté européenne
entament cette réunion il faut souligner
dans un climat plus serein que lors du
sommet de copenhague pas de dossiers
urgents en suspens et à l'issue de ce
conseil européen de hanovre françois
mitterrand recevra cette semaine les
principaux responsables politiques
français et nous verrons alors si un
consensus se dégage sur l'idée de mettre
en place dès 1990 une monnaie européenne
car dès ce moment là
les capitaux circuleront librement
georges bortoli le 31 décembre 1992 les
frontières européennes vont s'abaisser
ça nous le savons tous mais dès le 1er
juillet 90 dans deux ans donc les
capitaux vont commencer à circuler
librement entre les 12 pays de la
communauté
d'où l'idée de créer une monnaie
européenne commune émise par une banque
centrale ou fédéral européen
cette idée ambitieuse va dominer ce
sommet qui s'ouvre dans ce parc des
expositions de hanovre et je veux dire
que pour une fois c'est un sommet de
rêve car les finances de la communauté
étant d'assurer pour cinq ans il n'y a
pas de problème urgent à régler et on va
pouvoir penser à l'avenir
alors est ce à dire qu'il n'y aura pas
de discussions serrées si bien sûr
madame seule chair à son habitude va
jouer les cavaliers seuls
elle est allergique à l'idée que la
livre sterling pourrait sortir de son
splendide isolement pour se fondre dans
un système monétaire européen qui ne
respire que de la défiance
au fond c'est un premier sujet de
désaccord
et puis quel rôle dans l'élaboration de
cette nouvelle monnaie européenne
qu'elle roule 20 ont confié aux
gouverneurs des banques centrales la
banque de france val d'orge ou dess
banque est ce que ce sont ces éminents
techniciens qui vont être en charge de
ce projet ou bien sûr val confié à une
commission plus politique
alors entre ces hypothèses qui
s'affrontent il appartiendra peut-être à
la france de présenter une motion de
synthèse
le voyage de jean-paul ii en autriche
s'achève aujourd'hui
le pape doit regagner rome tard dans la
nuit c'était innsbruck qui sera la
dernière étape de ce voyage hier dans la
ville de mozart c'est à dire à salzbourg
jean paul ii a expliqué qu'il fallait
dire non à la peur à toutes les peurs et
ils fois de plus le saint père cherche à
développer le dialogue entre toutes les
communautés chrétiens musulmans juifs
voici un premier bilan avec jean claude
darrigrand
dernière étape donc du voyage de
jean-paul ii en autriche
innsbruck la capitale du trek à de
l'ecti roll une journée bilan puisque le
pape a repris à la messe de ce matin les
thèmes qu'il a abordés durant son
périple de cinq jours
on s'attendait un voyage délicat sous
tendu par la situation particulière de
courval d'eim en fait au delà de
quelques manifestations sporadiques rien
de décisif ne s'est passé et le pape
lors de sa visite au camp de mathausen
tout en stigmatisant à nouveau la
barbarie de terrienne s'est cantonné
dans son rôle de chef spirituel
il a rappelé le souvenir de marcel callo
le jeune jocistes mort en déportation
béatifiée par lui il y a quelques mois
il a demandé également que l'on prie
pour que disparaisse à jamais les
génocides une autre étape importante de
ce voyage la prière oecuménique avec des
protestants à salzbourg durant laquelle
jean paul ii n'hésita pas à demander
pardon pour les erreurs commises par
l'église catholique au moment de la
réforme
un voyage donc dont on retiendra surtout
l'aspect religieux les circonstances
ayant fait que l'incidence politique
possible du périple autrichien du pape
était finalement en grande partie
minimisée à la fois par les
circonstances et la volonté conjointe de
l'autriche et du vatican
nouvelle calédonie loyalistes et
indépendantistes ont donc défini avec
michel rocard avait conditions qui
devraient mener dans dix ans un scrutin
d'autodétermination de textes vous le
savez ont été signés l'un sur lequel il
y a un corps dedans c'est déjà un pilote
qui devrait être soumis par les deux
parties en présence
soumis à leur base et monsieur diva ou
que vous voyez ici avec monsieur lafleur
prévoit des discussions durent au sein
de son mouvement qui se réunira le 15
juillet alors voici les premiers
témoignages recueillis sur place et
enregistrés par nos collègues de rfo de
dix ans c'est rassurant pour certains
mais c'est comment un contrat
d'assurance ce qu'il faut lire c'est ce
qui est écrit en tout petits caractères
tout en bas de la page
et pour nous ça pourrait s'appeler par
exemple fiscalité des problèmes fonciers
il faut pas croire que le fln caisse et
les socialistes ont abandonné leur
projet d'indépendance
ça sera une grosse erreur ce qu'on voit
que dans cet accord il y a les
concessions et concessionnaires - ce
n'est le ksc peu de garanties pour les
loyalistes des concessions dans l'
annonce de scrutin d'autodétermination
dans dix ans c'est à dire ça correspond
à une remise en cause du scrutin qui a
eu lieu l'année dernière
ça veut dire que pendant dix ans
l'avenir va être hypothéqué parce qu'on
peut se demander quels sont les les
particuliers qui vont investir ne serait
ce que pour se construire une maison
qu'ils sont les industriels qui vont
faire des investissements dans le
territoire pour nous autres qui avons
soutenu l'élection des présidents de la
république de françois mitterrand
c'était précisément concurrents et nous
un tel dialogue que nous avons près tout
au long de cette campagne que nous avons
souhaité que dossier calédonien puissent
être pris que le statut pense puissent
être retirés qu'enfin on puisse examiner
sereinement notre avenir
quant aux nouveaux commentaires des
responsables politiques à paris simone
veil estime que l'accord signé dimanche
est un succès tout à fait remarquable je
la cite et laurent fabius lui dit que
tout cela ouvre une réelle possibilité
d'espoir d'accord mode d'emploi nous
allons revenir maintenant aux termes de
cet accord conclu hier entre les
loyalistes et les indépendantistes sur
la reprise par l'état du pouvoir
exécutif sur le territoire et puis sur
les projets qui devraient conduire donc
un référendum d'autodétermination dans
dix ans vous aurez donc compris qu'il ya
plusieurs étapes dans un premier temps
l'état français sera seul responsable du
territoire ces derniers mois quelques
prérogatives administratives avait été
confié aux régions voyons le détail tout
de tout cela avec dominique baert sur
une période de 12 mois
michel rocard propose que la nouvelle
calédonie soit géré directement par
paris autrement dit le pouvoir exécutif
est confiée non plus à des élus locaux
mais un haut commissaire représentant de
l'état
ce point a été acceptée par les deux
leaders de la négociation pour le reste
du processus
jacques lafleur et jean marie tjibaou se
sont engagés à présenter les
propositions du premier ministre à leur
base respective
le fln questionnera une convention
extraordinaire à la mi juillet la
négociation sera difficile reconnaissait
ce matin jean marie tjibaou
mais nous travaillons pour l'avenir le
premier ministre suggère la mise en
place d'un statut transitoire jusqu'en
1998 date à laquelle se tiendrait un
scrutin d'autodétermination tous les
français seraient appelés à se prononcer
par référendum sur l'ensemble du
processus
en septembre prochain dans ses nouvelles
institutions la nouvelle calédonie
serait une fédération composée de trois
provinces
l'une au sud à majorité européenne les
deux autres le nord et les îles loyauté
sont essentiellement mélanésienne un
important plan de développement
économique doit permettre d'effectuer un
ré
quilibre âge entre nouméa la capitale et
le reste du territoire
quant au scrutin d'autodétermination il
se tiendrait donc en 1998 pourrait y
participer les calédoniens inscrits sur
les listes électorales de la prochaine
consultation de 70 88 ainsi que leurs
enfants en âge de voter
tous devront résider sur le territoire à
la date du scrutin
la méthode rocard alors au moment où il
conclut ce premier accord entre les
parties adverses en nouvelle calédonie
tout le monde considère que c'est un
succès personnel pour le premier
ministre afin de mieux comprendre ce qui
devrait arriver dans les mois qui
viennent concernant des dossiers aussi
délicats ou ce qui pourrait arriver
examinons donc la méthode qui repose sur
ou deux ou trois piliers efficacité
sobriété pays ce création certains
parlent même de style mains des siens
gilles leclair pas nous expliquer de
quoi il s'agit exactement
mais cet accord salué par l'ensemble de
la classe politique comme une
performance donc bien à pic pour michel
rocard à quelques heures de la formation
de son second gouvernement il ya 48
heures de sa déclaration devant le
parlement à soir à une même table jean
marie tjibaou et jacques lafleur puisse
aboutir à un texte cette semaine
seulement après les événements d'ouvéa
était un pari mais un pari qui repose en
effet sur une méthode bien précises
pas de coups spectaculaires pas d'à
priori mais réalisme et efficacité
beaucoup de consultations une bonne
connaissance des dossiers et surtout pas
trop de publicité cela signifie en outre
la recherche de l'aide du plus grand
consensus possible et ne pas désigner de
vainqueur et de vaincus au discours
parfois floue et désordonnés sur
l'ouverture
michel rocard répond aujourd'hui par la
recherche du plus grand consensus
possible
c'est vrai pour la nouvelle calédonie
nous venons de le voir ce sera vrai
aussi pour d'autres d'autres dossiers
comme par exemple l'audiovisuel et
d'autres thèmes également 1,6 en état de
grâce soumis à des pressions diverses y
compris dans son propre camp
michel rocard marque un point il lui
restera bien sûr à transformer cet essai
par le vote à l'automne du projet doit
pas seulement parler seul socialiste par
le succès du référendum et surtout par
la situation sur le terrain nous n'en
sommes il faut rappeler qu'à la première
les gîtes puisque vous parliez de
l'audiovisuel jacques lang propose un
conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel qui
remplacerait la cncl l'actuelle autorité
mais il souhaite que la réforme ne soit
pas bâclée et il parle d'un délai de
trois mois à la politique encore avec la
suite de la bataille pour la mairie de
marseille
un vote devait devrait même intervenir
ce soir entre les militants socialistes
pour choisir leur candidat à la mairie
robert vigouroux refus ce scrutin il le
considère sans valeur je vous rappelle
qu'il est en course contre nous autres
candidats socialistes michel petit nous
allons maintenant tout de suite à la
bourse non sans vous avoir annoncé
auparavant que juste après jean leber
vous retrouverez et c'est une
exclusivité antenne 2 alain delon sur
une patte
parce que l'hôte et dans le plâtre il
vient d'être hospitalisé victime d'une
rupture de ligament c'est dans un
instant tout de suite ces messieurs le
berre qui va bien vous voyez pas permis
la bourse baisse légèrement
oui elles baissent légèrement en fait la
forte hausse du dollar a stoppé les
velléités de hausse de la bourse de
paris william à 6 francs 14 60
le dollar gagne 10 centimes par rapport
à son cours de vendredi la hausse trop
rapide du dollar inquiète les boursiers
ils ont peur que cela oblige les
allemands à monter leurs taux d'intérêt
et du même coup à nous empêcher nous de
les baisser alors ça a un effet négatif
sur la bourse et nous allons le voir
tout à l'heure elle baisse pour
l'instant la livre sterling elle est en
légère baisse à 10 francs 53 disent
toutes marques et calme en recul face
aux grains français à 3 francs 36 75 et
les culés tu la monnaie européenne au
centre des conversations du sommet de
hanovre est à 7 francs
la figure comme vous le savez pour les
actions marché sélectif et prises de
bénéfices indicateurs de tendance recul
de 0,24 % et sur notre tableau des plus
fortes variations à la baisse darty perd
un peu plus de 4% de même que casino est
peinard ouailles à schneider 3 19% une
chine sun -3 7%
les privatiser sont irrégulières paribas
gagne 70 centimes saint gobain perd 7
francs ces jeunes perd 3 francs 50 suez
6 francs mais la générale gagne 3 francs
sur le marché de l'or toujours aussi peu
de choses à dire à 86 1500 le n'impote
le kg a gagné 100 francs et le napoléon
à 503 francs répète son cours de
vendredi
voilà où il ya une bonne séance de
consolidation à la bourse de paris dans
un marché sélectif
sur le plan social les boursiers
seraient parvenus à un accord attention
il ya encore quelques petites
perturbations dues à la réorganisation
de la bourse il n'y a pas de sociétés
étrangères cotées au règlement mensuel
encore aujourd'hui prenez un merci jean
à demain à comme achille a comme alain
alain delon l'un et l'autre ont en
commun un talon fragile et la star bien
en faire la cruelle démonstration au
cours d'une scène de ne réveillez pas un
flic qui dort de josé pinheiro
l'accident ligaments déchirés
hospitalisation le secret avait été bien
gardé mais nous savons tous entrée à la
clinique des maussins mardi dernier
opéré le lendemain il est sorti hier
dimanche le producteur de nom reviendra
sur le tournage pour le superviser avec
bientôt les scènes où joue michel
serrault quant à l'acteur de long et
bien dans six semaines il pourra de
nouveau courir une seule équipe de
télévision était donc présenté hier et
dans le rôle du reporter de nous william
lui même il m'est arrivé il m'arrivait
rien je me suis rompu le tendon
d'achille à tout le monde le sait ben
non justement
on se savait atteint monde le sait pas
alors voilà au cours d'une tour d'une
scène du tournage de mon père les films
saviez pas un flic qui dort
le flip fixé - et donc dans une scène de
poursuite qui se passait dans les
couloirs de la posture rubrique j'ai
couru comme manager sauter trois marches
banal et puis plage ou s'ils ont plutôt
la chine stigmates danger un point
commun avec achille et j'en suis fier je
fais c'est à dire moins que de la est ce
que pour autant ce genre de scène c'est
terminé
vous allez maintenant vous allez faire
le père du commissaire d'antan chafic
je connais votre humour légendaire ou
chaoui le film va reprendre
j'aurais semble prêt à tourner je
respecte surtout medac de sortie je ne
jouerai pas le père du commissaire le
resterai ici génère greendale que je
suis mais alors est-ce que c'est amusant
au fond de faire encore des rôles comme
cela je crois me souvenir que vous
alliez quelques conseils vous parler de
mon côté j'ai une grande admiration pour
charles vanel vous avez vieillit et le
william une valeur ne vieillit pas
mettez vous bien ça dans ma tête c'est
comme un noeud pied ipa copains à ok ma
compagne elle coûte ce soir et je vais
faire un petit déjeuner et déjeuner le
matin
ça va ça va bien
j'ai voté oui pour la jambe droite
alors ne lui dites pas en ce moment
c'est le pied parce que le bourg ce pas
très drôle et puis ça ferait pas rire en
revanche comme vous nous bien nous lui
souhaitons pas ce que je sais qu'ils
regardent ce journal lui souhaitons un
très prompt rétablissement à bientôt
si vous aimez vous faire peur ne fait
pas comme ça mais je vais vous donner la
bonne direction c'est cergy-pontoise
mirapolis il ya du nouveau dans les
attractions figurez vous le roller
coaster vous ne connaissez pas moi non
plus mais enfin c'est le premier en
france
explications et démonstrations dans un
autre et pas par n'importe qui puisque
johnny hallyday carlos ont testé pour
nous cette nouvelle machine une
attraction qui vous sera présenté dès
mercredi reportage jean jacques dufour
quand johnny ce n'est pas un coup
d'essai le rôle coster il connaît bien
je crois que celui-ci doit être plus
âpre selon tommy jackson lorsqu'il n'y a
plus le looping en a pas dites moi vous
vous êtes toujours passionné de vitesse
moto voiture vous avez laissé tomber
maintenant on a la preuve victor une
attitude rock pour une machine roll et
bien c'est une grosse bestiole qui fait
à peu près 30 mètres de haut qui descend
à 80 km heure avant de prendre le
premier looping avec une force de 3g qui
correspond à un petit peu à ce qu'on
ressent dans la patrouille de france
paraît-il en petits vols supersoniques
elle pèse 900 tonnes la structure et
c'est un petit joujou qui coûte entre 25
et 28 ans francs
[ __ ]
la mort
adedy
attention à vos lunettes ça fait cinq
ans que les désaccords qu'on va perdre
voilà les pires propos quel regard
johnny pose-t-il sur la vedette michael
jackson c'est pas trop mon truc mais sur
scène et paraît qu'il est formidable
sur scène johnny sera tout le mois de
juillet côté provence côte d'azur
j'ai fait revenir plus tôt mais mais qu
aurait déjà j'aimais tout ça pour 4 5
jours c'était un peu court alors là
d'essayer de le faire tout le noir c'est
vous manque vous tombe était sur scène
j'aime bien les tournées j'aime bien
l'ambiance
alors allez roulez petit bolide
dames
petit bolide petit bolide qu'archos
tiens à propos de costaud alors la boxe
maintenant le match de tous les excès
cette nuit les costauds s'affrontent à
atlantic city c'est une sorte de las
vegas de la côte-est tisonne recevra
quoi qu'il arrive 126 millions de francs
et spinks 81 millions de francs bah
seulement oui ça fait cher le pain et le
titre même du combat once and for all
ah oui en français une fois pour toutes
et bien cela traduit l'enjeu car il
s'agit de connaître enfin qui est le
meilleur boxeur du monde puisqu'ils sont
là et l'autre a vaincu patrick mantel
dans les points de mike tyson tout le
poids de la démesure d'un nouveau combat
du siècle
bien plus que les 2 kg 700 qui sépare
sur la balance phison de son challenger
michael spinks 420 millions de francs de
recettes brutes pour le combat de tous
les records
9000 francs déboursés pour chacun des 21
mille cinq cents privilégiés
réunis dans le convention center
d'atlantic city un engouement sans
précédent qui s'explique aussi par le
palmarès de michael spinks à 30 2 1
l'ancien champion olympique de montréal
invaincu en 31 combats professionnels
est le seul à pouvoir stopper ce tyson
son seul handicap
le poids des années dix ans de plus que
tyson mais une chance réelle tout de
même car tyson traverse une passe
difficile
la mort de son père adoptif oussama tôt
celui qui a su transformer le délinquant
du bronx en machine à boxer et puis ses
démêlés conjugaux avec la belle actrice
robin given une véritable série
américaine ou derrière la passion perse
le plus souvent des rapports violents
est intéressé bref le boxing business
dans tous ses excès reste à savoir si
tyson à 22 ans a su suffisamment se
préserver pour préparer sereinement ce
combat le public et les bookmakers le
pense plus nuancée en revanche les
pronostics des anciens maîtres du ring à
commencer par cassius clay et sugar ray
leonard qui pronostique une victoire aux
points de michael spinks pour son combat
d'adieu à sa condition toutefois qu'ils
puissent neutraliser la formidable force
de frappe du tenant du titre voici
maintenant quelque chose d'un peu plus
calme il s'agit d'une compétition
européenne très sérieuse qui s'est
déroulée
ces deux derniers jours dans la banlieue
lyonnaise s'agit de voitures miniatures
télécommandés et il ya pour cette
discipline de véritable maniaque car ils
reproduisent en tout petit toutes les
pièces reportage claude reicha une vraie
course
un public jeune passionné des pilotes
champions qui ne sont pas des as au 10e
les compétitions ne modèle réduit
radiocommandé ont une ressemblance très
marqué avec celle des aînés de la
formule un tueur un circuit polyglotte
on a vécu trois jours très fort séance
de qualifications mêmes réglages pointus
des moteurs électriques
dernière mise au point des pneus bref un
véritable sport mécanique souhaite une
discipline très spectaculaire les
voitures ont des performances
exceptionnelles doivent sauter des boss
se glisse dans les virages on est
vraiment à une échelle réduite
toutes les performances des vraies
voitures qu'on connaît au paris dakar ou
ailleurs qu'est ce qui compte le plus
c'est le pilotage aussi la mécanique au
niveau des qualifications c'est d'abord
la mécanique parce qu'il faut trouver
tout de suite et très rapidement les
bons réglages avec les bons pneus les
bons moteurs les bons vins qu il faut
trouver le bon feeling trouvait tout de
suite la bonne accroche la motricité
par contre à ce niveau là samedi nous en
sommes au stade final puisqu'on va
disputer toutes les grandes finales et
là c'est vraiment ce qui c'est la tête
du pilote qui fait rend tous et son
talent un petit coup de chapeau pour la
meilleure carrosserie elle est italienne
bien sûr le prost des minis bolides
le champion d'europe c'est lui denis
blandin un français qui l'a emporté en
trois manches face à neuf concurrents
européens dont des anglais jusque là
considérées comme les plus performants
comme ces bolides lancés à 45 kilomètres
heure le marché de la voiture
radiocommandée fait des bonds
la compétition est un tremplin pour un
secteur en expansion
il y à déjà 5000 licenciés en france
vous avez été surpris avec des images
d'alain delon de johnny hallyday ces
petits bolides ça n'est pas fini
parce qu'une première ce soir à
montpellier un spectacle intitulé fric
ce que l'on pourrait traduire par les
monstres ou les phénomènes s'est adapté
du célèbre film de tod browning en noir
et blanc qui date de 1932 et ce film
raconte la vie le travail les amours les
haines aussi d'une troupe de phénomène
du cirque wasyl reportage de jorge ben
bekou cette jeune femme qui balance
entre ciel et terre
c'est geneviève de kermabon elle a mis
cinq ans à réaliser son rêve adapter un
film au théâtre c'est fric c'est mon
passe quand il ya écrit acrobates parce
que c'est le métier que je pratique
depuis une douzaine d'années je me faire
des disciplines de cirque mais sûrement
pas du cirque qui est important c'est ce
que les gens ont de dents à l'intérieur
et on est un tout on est aussi un corps
donc j'ai toujours voulu éviter deux
choses dans freaks et d'une part l'armée
du salut justement parce qu'on a
toujours tendance à temps a aplani les
handicapés pas du tout si c'est des gens
du moment qu'on à sa tête à soi quand on
dépasse ça y est on a pas du tout avoir
de a les pleins de la compassion pour
ont cessé à chacun sa nature et d'une
autre part c'est justement
l'exhibitionnisme c'est-à-dire
l'exhibition open la foire du trône et
ça je veux pas du tout non plus quoi je
voudrais que tout le monde soit le plus
beau possible
sans compte pas
parce que jamais
ces commandes les bébés
mais jamais dans la seconde
l'intensité du jeu est telle que le
spectateur oublie peu à peu le handicap
des comédiens acrobates
il prend à son compte le drame qui se
joue et se laisse gagner par l'émotion
jusqu'à la fin du spectacle
voilà ce journal est à présent terminée
dans un instant c'est sophie davant et
la météo patricia et moi et toute
l'équipe de la mi journée on vous
retrouve demain même heure même endroit
c'est 13h sur antenne 2 en après midi ce
soir 20h henri sannier au revoir
m